start with why is about attracting
people and and being
and having and having unbridled
inspiration and passion for your own
work
um but what do you do once you've
attracted the people like what do you do
when you have the team that goes we
believe
now what um and um and simultaneously i
was
spending a lot of time with folks in the
military and i kept meeting these people
who would who would literally give their
lives to save the life of somebody they
don't even like
you know and and i don't have any of
those relationships at work
you know and i sort of would would sort
of joke semi that you know
in in the military they give medals to
people who willing to sacrifice
themselves that others may gain
and in business we give bonuses to
people who are willing to sacrifice
others so that we may gain
and i just quite frankly wanted to
understand where how where did their
trust
come from and my initial uh uh uh
theory was because they're better people
and you
tend to find more of them in in these
kinds of industries in in in those kinds
of professions
because good people are attracted to
service i was completely wrong
it's not the people it's the environment
and this is what circles of safety are
all about which is if you can create an
environment this is the responsibility
of leaders
which is if you can create an
environment in which people feel
psychologically safe
what you get is trust what you get is
their desire
to to try new things and push boundaries
what you get is people
asking better questions because they
feel psychologically safe to do so